national lobster day is coming up
chef stephen hop craft is with us you
know we went i'm not to cut you off but
we went all the way into lobster month
we're going to run this thing the whole
month the world
day is actually september 25th
right but but you're saying is that the
day after the beginning of fall is it or
maybe it's the day before i i just tried
to stop i
know myself all i know is lobster day
that's what's on my calendar i like it
it's a big day and we already started
decorating
so
what are you doing for lobster month stk
we've got a few things going on here um
of course the first thing we have is a
little appetizer with compressed
watermelon salad we got a little ginger
mint lime uh little sauce there
vinaigrette and then we got some
tagarashi and and that came together
really nice for us um as far as entrees
go we got this rigatoni with just all
kinds of spice in it clams lobster just
right off the right off the couch is
that you yeah that's a beautiful
presentation oh i really appreciate it
man yeah yeah we're trying to put it
together you know make our lobsters look
good
you know they crawl around in the bottom
of the ocean for so long you know they
give them give them some points for
style yeah how often do you have
lobsters flown in
uh daily yeah
daily
i mean
they come in we only get the ones that
are suicidal so i don't want anybody to
worry about that
so you know we're just trying to help
out the environment and it's a
first-class flight
yes first class they get cocktails like
the whole nines and what are you doing
here tell us okay so this is our ravioli
this is like a
lemon emulsion
and it goes with we got a little um
a little uh squash puree in there and of
course
here's the star of our show
little lobster bits
which i perfectly like
and this is an entree portion
we do it as an appetizer as well it's
fun to share
you know what i love about having you
around stephen is you i feel you no
seriously your passion your passion for
cooking it comes across so much and
obviously people go visit you at stk i
do that i do have a lot of friends there
and we we really appreciate all our
locals and everybody that comes up and
sees us because you know it's a party
atmosphere but nobody knows how to party
and nobody knows how to fun have fun
like the locals of las vegas so we love
to have you guys and we love to see you
in there yeah yeah well this is
beautiful all of it smells amazing oh
watch out little shark attack right
there
i know i noticed that that's
it's at the cosmopolitan right yeah
we're on the third floor at the cosmo uh
cosmopolitan of las vegas we'd love to
come and see ya or have you come and see
us anyway and um reservation's a good
idea uh you just need a reservation okay
yeah we're doing a happy hour these days
and of course we have our brunch
love to see you for brunch um you know
we're just hitting on all cylinders and
like we were talking about earlier vegas
is coming back super stronger than ever
love it and you guys are all a big part
of that i love it i have no reservations
in saying stk is awesome
steven we will be right back